again my name is Anna knuckles
how can we help you and Liam on a
plumber Winkle
okay I'm not really catching what you're
saying dear where are you from
originally
Murphy's myrn things mean you're from
Memphis Tennessee Martha no Oh
Murfreesboro okay is that where you were
born
no I was born in Nashville
okay but you were born in the US okay so
what is your problem come on what is
your problem having trouble with
breathing okay
now have you had heavy as a kid no I
didn't I was fine with asthma a year God
okay how old are you now
I'm Flemming than mine okay how many
skin problems and eczema dermatitis
psoriasis or rosacea no okay any high
blood pressure diabetes or arthritis
oh okay type 2a no onset time soon okay
and how much do you weigh mmm 12 to 12
and how tall are you dear all right 5
foot even right okay well 5 foot I'd
like to see you weigh about a hundred
pounds we need to lose 112 pounds okay
yeah okay so Charmaine what's going on
here she's got asthma she had trouble
breathing what's going on
small asthma you know probably she's got
a gluten intolerance you can't break
down the AFAs okay well actually you
can't absorb the EF phase right right
okay and also when when you have a
gluten problem it's not unusual to gain
weight and be obese okay and let's see
here and in 79 probably I would guess a
little bit of osteoporosis or arthritis
also but she does also have type-2
diabetes so what would you what would
you give
I know for her various problems here to
support her body's ability to heal
itself well I would get around to for
those issues I'd get around to healthy
blood sugar packs but I'd also add the
gluco gel and MSM and the vitamin d3
okay very good yep
you need to get rid of all the bad foods
I had no fried foods no process means
for nitrates and nitrites no oils no
olive oil coconut oil margins mayonnaise
hydrogen cooking oils no gluten no wheat
no Brian oats everybody in the household
dog cat bird fish renter spouse partner
kids grandkids everybody in the
household is got to be gluten free no
wheat bran rhinos and then since you're
diabetic you also need to be sugar-free
no juice no fruit and no sugars agave
syrup maple syrup molasses honey all
that stuff's got to go certainly table
sugar and then ash are said it's a good
idea to get two healthy blood sugar
packs take a full dose or think twice a
day and then before you medicate
yourself every morning take your fancy
blood sugar and as your blood sugar
drops and it will you need to reduce
your medications your doctor taught you
to do the goal is to get your blood
sugar total blood sugar down below 100
without medication and because you have
probably a little bit like if the
arthritis osteoporosis as shar said I
haven't throw in two bottles of the
gluco gel so you take 15 capsules a day
five five and five five with each meal
or you can take two quarts of the liquid
and take in an ounce twice a day of the
liquid glucose el those are two options
and then the MSM I'd take three of those
tablets at breakfast and dinner that's
from our free live division and they
really really really support the
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between a vertebrae bone matrix
bone cell and what would you give her a
charmaine to help her encourage your
body to lose the weight
oh the rav of course rev yes and because
you need to lose more than a hundred
pounds I would get two bottles of the
revit per month if you can only afford
one get one but ideally you would get
two
so you can take a dropper full twice a
day or twice before each meal that these
six drivers full of days that requires
two models and months to do that
you want a dropper full under your
tongue how to drop it a dropper full on
your tongue 30 minutes for each meal the
second dropper full on your tongue 15
minutes for each meal and within a
couple of days you'll start losing a
half a pound of 2 pounds a day it'll be
a healthy weight loss later taking in
all these nutrients and so we would like
you to call us every couple of weeks in
Tennessee we actually have a warehouse
as ships when you put it in your order
tell them that you live in Tennessee of
course you're going to give me Rand rest
and let them know that you'd like your
order ship from the Memphis warehouse
you'll get it within a couple of days
that way and because it ships from the
West Coast so let's say maybe it's three
to five days to get to you you can start
the diet immediately when you hang up
give us a call and and we'll you know
see that you get what you need to get
and it's not unusual for these things to
go away fairly quickly and to lose again
I have a pound two pounds I think and
you will be a new woman here pretty
quickly